notre réunion de CE ce jour mes chers
collègues avant toute chose je veux ici
dire évidemment et réitérer notre
solidarité avec le peuple israélien et
notre condamnation sans équivoque des
effroyables actes terroristes qui
touchent Israël depuis samedi des
centaines peut-être des milliers de
victimes civiles ont été lâchement
abatttu par des terroristes du Hamas
parce que Juive parmi elles des femmes
des enfants des bébés des vieillards des
jeunes qui participaient à un festival
de musique des citoyens français et
d'autres de nombreuses nationalités nos
pensées vont évidemment aux victimes et
à leurs proches ainsi qu'aux otages
retenus à Gaza par le Hamas qui font
l'objet d'un chantage insupportable et
je veux évidemment redire dans ce moment
tragique que nous sommes au côté des
familles endeuillées et que N et que
toutes les et de toutes les victimes de
ces attaques barbares et que nous sommes
tous animés par une volonté commune ne
laisser aucune place au terrorisme et
créer les conditions d'une paix durable
au Moyen-Orient je vous remercie je vi
vient tout de suite à l'ordre du jour de
notre réunion qui appelle l'examen de
deux rapports d'information nous allons
commencer par le premier sur la sécurité
énergétique et la réforme du marché de
l'énergie que vont nous présenter nos
collègues Pascal Boyet et Nathalie
osiol sur ce sujet nous avons un défi de
court terme qui est notre compétitivité
énergétique et nous avons aussi à bâtir
un modèle à moyen terme qui doit nous
permettre d'aller vers la neutralité
carbone à l'horizon 2050 en parle
de modèles nationaux comme vous le savez
au sein de l'Union européenne qui sont
extrêmement différents et pour ce faire
je crois que nous avons besoin de plus
de renouvelable de plus de nucléaire et
au fond de plus d'intégration électrique
en Europe nous ne sommes évidemment pas
tous d'accord sur cet agenda au sein des
27 et certainement aussi au sein de
cette commission et donc il va falloir
démultiplier les efforts je pense que
c'est une une véritable préoccupation et
ce serait une erreur historique euh de
nous priver de nucléaire ou de ralentir
les investissements en la matière de en
matière de nucléaire et d'innovation et
donc notre priorité au sein de l'Union
européenne ne doit évidemment pas être
de nous diviser sur des modèles
énergétiques qui sont différents mais au
contraire de renforcer l'intégration
électrique du réseau l'intégration du
réseau électrique européen ce qui est
absolument indispensable parce qu'on va
devoir évidemment électrifier de plus en
plus à cet égard il y a eu des
discussions importantes qui ont eu lieu
lundi et et hier à Hambourg entre les
gouvernement français et allemand entre
le chancelier SCHS et le président
Emmanuel Macron et qui ont acté de
pouvoir travailler ensemble dans les
semaines à venir pour chercher à
conclure d'ici à la fin du mois un
accord nécessaire voilà donc sans plus
attendre je laisse la parole à nos
collègues rapporteurs en commençant par
Pascal
Boyet merci monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues tout d'abord je voudrais
formuler mes remerciement à Monsieur
Marcelo François notre administrateur
qui nous a suivi pendant cette longue
mission qui a dur à peu près 9 mois et
aux collaborateurs de la commission des
affaires
européennes je sors de ces 9 mois de
travail sur le rapport d'information
avec un sentiment de fierté de l'Union
européenne d'avoir su abolir ses
mantrats et agir rapidement pour la
protection des consommateurs même si
beaucoup restent à faire en matière de
sécurité énergétique face à la
volatilité des prix de l'énergie
l'Europe a en effet su jouer un rôle
protecteur pour les citoyens et les
entreprises durant l'année écoulée
remémorons-nous un instant le mois
d'octobre 2022 il y a 1 an à l'approche
de l'hiver nous craignions des périodes
de blackout avec des des possibles
périodes de délestage lors des pics de
consommation
d'électricité souvenonsnous aussi de
notre crainte de financer l'effort de
guerre russe par l'achat de quantités
massives de gaz en à de gaz à gaz Prom
souvenons-nous enfin des efforts
demandés aux consommateurs qui malgré
l'instauration d'un bouclier tarifaire
efficace au niveau national ont vu leur
facture d'énergie augmenter un an après
tout n'est pas résolu mais l'Union
européenne tout comme la France ont agi
les mesures d'urgence ont en effet
permis à l'Union diviser par 5 de
diviser par 5 les importations de gaz
russes dans l'union de remplir les
stocks de gaz en prévision de l'hiver
prochain et de financer les dispositifs
de protection des consommateurs par
l'instauration d'une taxe sur les
producteurs inframarginaux d'électricité
ou une contribution exceptionnelle de
solidarité sur les producteurs d'énergie
fossile audà de ces mesures d'urgence
les objectifs de la politique
énergétique ont évolué se sont renforcés
et ne sont plus contesté ma
corrapporteur et moi-même les partageons
d'ailleurs ce qui nous a permis de vous
soumettre aujourd'hui avec ce rapport
une dizaine de recommandations
consensuelles ce sont toutefois les
moyens à mobiliser pour atteindre ces
objectifs qui font objet d'un désaccord
entre nous dessinant ainsi très
clairement deux projets deux
trajectoires de ce que doit être la
politique de l'énergie au niveau
national et
européen le premier objectif est le
verdissement du mix énergétique l'Europe
que nous avons bâti est le continent le
plus ambitieux pour la décarbonation du
mix énergétique ces sujets me tiennent
particulièrement à cœur notamment en cas
en tant que président du groupe d'étude
énergie durable et hydrogène à
l'Assemblée nationale pour pour y
parvenir l'Union déploie une série de
textes dans le cadre du Pacte vert pour
l'Europe et du paquet fit for
45 55 pardon la directive red 3
récemment adoptée relève ainsi la part
d'énergie renouvelable à 42,5 % dans le
mix énergétique de l'Union à l'Union à
l'horizon 2030 au lieu de 32 %
précédemment je crois toutefois que
l'atteint de l'objectif de décarbonation
du mixe ne peut reposer uniquement sur
les les énergies renouvelables
naturellement l'hydrogène est un vecteur
formidable d'espoir pour décarboner
plusieurs secteurs comme les mobilités
lourdes mais pour la production
d'électricité nous ne pouvons pas
envisager un mix sans une part
importante de nucléaire qui est une
technologie décarboné pilotable et peu
chè je suis toujours étonné de voir que
durant les 15 dernières années aucun
texte relatif au nucléaire n'a été
adopté au niveau européen et que le
pacte vert pour l'Europe ne mentionne
quasiment pas cette technologie d'avenir
aux opposants du nucléaire je pose une
question simple pourquoi se priver du
moyen de production le plus sûr et
pilotable à l'heure où nous avons des
efforts considérables à déployer pour
atteindre la la neutralité carbone à
l'horizon 2050 le mixénergétique
européen a besoin du nucléaire pour
atteindre ses objectifs c'est un des
axes forts de ma contribution au rapport
le second objectif de la politique
énergétique est l'indépendance du mix
nous ne pouvons en tant qu'Européen
pactisé avec des pays tiers peu fiables
pour l'importation de notre énergie nous
avons ainsi réduit réussi à réduire très
fortement notre dépendance vis-à-vis de
la Russie pourtant les récents
événements avec le haut carabak nous
rappellent tristement que l'Azerbaïjan
avec laquelle l'Union a pourant signé un
partenariat énergétique à l'été 2022 ne
peut-être un associé fiable pour
l'importation de gaz les régimes
illibéraux ou autoritaires doivent ainsi
être bannis de toute fusion de
partenariat avec l'Union européenne le
plan REpower eu prévoit une
diversification des approvisionnement et
sa mise en œuvre a permis de trouver des
partenaires crédibles je tiens à
souligner que la Norvège qui exporte un
terrawatur de gaz par jour sur le marché
européen et où je me suis rendu dans le
cadre de ce rapport présente toutes les
garanties de fiabilité
nécessaires le trème objectif est celui
au cœur de notre actualité européenne
depuis le début de l'année 2023 la
réforme du marché de l'électricité
depuis 2021 ce marché a joué son rôle de
marché permettant une allocution
optimale des ressources mais la
volatilité des prix à court terme a
provoqué des situations inacceptables
qui doivent aujourd'hui être corriger
nous devons absolument rapprocher les
prix des coûts de production notamment
en France où les coûts de fonctionnement
du nucléaire et les énergies
renouvlables sont relativement faibles
pour cela la Commission européenne
propose une solution le développement
d'un marché de long terme européen la
logique est la suivante si les prix sur
le marché de court terme dis spot sont
imprévisible et sujet à des envolés
soudaines il est alors nécessaire de
protéger les consommateurs en leur
procurant un prix fixe sur le moyen
terme c'est tout l'objectif des deux
types de contrats promus par la
Commission européenne le premier type de
contrat sont les pipers qui sont des
contrats de gré à gré entre particuliers
je m'explique une usine d'acier pour
ainsi traiter directement avec un
producteur d'électricité décarboné pour
s'assurer pendant 4 ou 5 ans une
fourniture d'électricité à un prix fixe
et négocié le second type de contrat
sont des contrats pour la différence qui
fixe un prix plancher et un prix plafond
garanti par l'État entre le producteurs
et les consommateurs prenons l'exemple
si le prix plafond fixé par le contrat
est de 70 € par MWh et que le prix
journalier de marché est de 100 € les
producteurs devront reverser 30 € à
l'état pour chaque Gaw produit pendant
7ette he c'est ce second type de contrat
qui est au cœur des négociations
bruxelloises en ce moment même ce
rapport est également un moyen de
soutenir pleinement en mon nom propre et
au nom du groupe Renaissance la position
française qui souhaite inclure
l'ensemble des installation existante
dans ces contrats notamment notre
nucléaire ancien je souhaite également
que la
redistribution des recettes issues des
contrats pour la différence puissent se
faire librement et que chaque État
puisse décider de leur utilisation pour
protéger les consommateurs je le répète
le marché n'est pas le problème il a
fonctionné correctement pendant la crise
toute solution de sortie du marché
serait non seulement un signal
profondément anti-européen envoyé par la
France mais aussi une solution simpliste
irréaliste qui nous priverait sans doute
d'un mécanisme performant d'échange avec
nos voisins il est également
complètement utopique mais dangereux
pour notre sécurité d'approvisionnement
de vouloir en même temps sortir du
nucléaire et sortir du marché européen
simplement le fonctionnement normal du
marché doit être complété pour protéger
tous nos consommateurs et je soutiens
ainsi le principe de la réforme portée
par la Commission européenne simplement
cette réforme doit inclure l'ensemble
des technologies décarbonées y compris
les installations nucléaires existantes
pour atteindre le triple objectif de
décarbonation d'autonomie stratégique et
de protection des consommateurs et j'ai
confiance dans notre Union européenne
pour atteindre cet objectif et poursuiv
poursuivre le travail ambitieux engagé
depuis plus d'un an je laisse la parole
à à ma collègue Nathalie osiol avec qui
nous avons travaillé pendant de nombreux
mois sur ce sur ce rapport et que je
remerci voilà pour cette pour ces
échanges cordials et et et des fois un
petit peu on va pas dire tendu mais on a
on a eu des discussions qui étaient
extrêmement riches et et donc voilà
c'est ce qui nourrit aussi notre rapport
et c'est ce qui nourrit aussi les
échanges
merci
et bien merci Madame Boyer mes chers
collègues je tiens à remercier d'abord
l'ensemble des personnes que nous avons
eu l'occasion d'auditionner dans le
cadre de ce rapport qui a duré
effectivement presque un
an je tiens pour ma part à remercier en
particulier Marina mesure qui en plus
d'être député européenne et rapporteur
fictive sur la réforme du marché au
Parlement européen pour le groupe la
gauche je tiens à remercier Anne de
brjas économiste notamment de l'énergie
et je fais mienne leur je fais mien leur
discours en particulier sur ce sujet là
je remercie également évidemment
monsieur Marcelo qui nous a accompagné
tous et mois et mes collaborateurs
romain prello et Anaïse de Saint-Martin
vous l'aurez compris nous défendons donc
deux projets différents qui reposent sur
deux aspects principaux le premier est
celui des prix de l'énergie de
l'électricité en particulier qui pose
par conséquent la question de rester ou
non dans le cadre du marché européen et
le deuxième aspect est celui de la
composition du mix énergétique français
et européen à horizon 2050 sur ces deux
questions majeures notre vision est
opposée avec ma co rapporteur mais nous
regrettons toutes les deux à l'image des
groupes the left et d'une partie de
renew le refus de débat sur ces sujets
en plinière du Parlement européen la
première question fondamentale sur
laquelle nous avons un désaccord avec ma
co-rapporteur et la méthode de fixation
des prix depuis plus de 30 ans l'Union
européenne applique une doctrine
libérale qui a conduit du à l'ouverture
de la concurrence nationale et
européenne de la production et de la
commercialisation de l'électricité
tandis que le transport et la
distribution relève de monopole régulé
cette politique a conduit notamment EDF
à céder des parts de marché à des
fournisseurs alternatifs sur l'activité
de commercialisation et à faire une
place aux producteurs privés la promesse
initiale était une baisse des prix pour
les consommateurs et des investissement
massif d'acteurs privés pour la
promotion de nouveaux moyens de
production quel est le bilan aujourd'hui
on a compté jusqu'à 80 fournisseurs
alternatifs en France mais leur nombre a
chuté avec la crise à ce jour 44 % du
volume d'électricité est vendu par ses
fournisseurs et 15 % du parc de
production est exploité par des acteurs
privés la mise en place du marché de
gros à l'échelle européenne a conduit à
ce que le prix de l'électricité soit
déterminé par le coût marginal de la
dernière unité appelée c'est-à-dire la
plus chère et c'est donc le plus souvent
corrélé au coût du gaz dont les prix
sont extrêmement volatiles
incontrôlables et sans lien avec le coût
réel de produit production de
l'électricité les écarts entre les prix
de marché et le coût de l'électricité
ont provoqué une succession de crise
depuis l'ouverture des marchés si bien
que tantôt c'est l'équilibre économique
des producteurs qui s'est retrouvé en
danger lorsque le prix était inférieur
au coût tantôt c'est le porte-monnaie
des consommateur qu'il a été lorsque le
prix était supérieur et depuis l'été
2021 les prix du gaz se sont envolés
entraînant aussi cell des prix de
l'électricité tandis que les coûts de
production eux n'étaient pas impactés
dans les mêmes proportions pour
illustrer ça le coût de production moyen
d'un mgawh reste inférieur à 100 € en
France les prix de marché ont dépassé
les 1000 € à l'été
2022 ainsi les familles artisans TPE PME
collectivité industrie ont vu leur
facture d'électricité multiplié par 3
par 4 jusqu'à 10 du côté de l'offre très
peu d'acteurs privés sont réellement
intéressés pour investir dans le secteur
de la production d'électricité puisque
les revenus sont rendus incertains par
le fonctionnement des
marchés au-delà du marché de
l'électricité d'ailleurs les seuls à
avoir tiré profit des règles libérales
et de la trèstimide de taxation des
super profits sont les grandes
entreprises comme Total qui a vu ses
profits augmenter de 41 % en 2022 par
l'exploitation de ressources fossiles et
par les bénéfices tirés de la guerre en
Ukraine lorsque nous avons auditionné la
commission durant notre déplacement à
Bruxelles au mois de septembre l'unique
solution envisagée est le renforcement
du marché sans jamais de bilan tiré des
échecs du marché or le marché est
incapable de proposer des prix de
l'électricité qui assure une stabilité
de la rémunération pour les producteurs
et de la tarification pour les
consommateurs la triple contrainte pour
une lecture transparente des prix pour
un recouvrement des coûts de production
et pour une équité de traitement dans
l'accès à un bien essentiel ne peut être
respecté que par la mise en place de
tarifs réglementés pour tous les
consommateurs or la fixation des tarifs
est un outil de politique publique qui
doit répondre à des attentes politique
écologique et social évidemment la mise
en place d'une grille tarifaire basée
sur les les coûts de production implique
de passer des de se passer pardon des
fournisseurs qui pratiquent l'achat et
la revente d'électricité souvent au
détriment des consommateurs c'est
pourquoi je porte dans ce rapport la
position d'une sortie de marché et de la
concurrence pour confier l'exploitation
du système électrique français à un
acteur public centralisé en fait
l'exploitation du système électrique
nécessite de définir le niveau de
production de chaque centrale à chaque
heure de manière à minimiser les coûts
d'exploitation de l'ensemble du parc
européen dans la logique de
l'élaboration du programme d'appel
il est indispensable de donner aux
investisseurs une visibilité sur la
rémunération des centrales sur
l'ensemble de leur durée de vie cela
nécessite la mise en place de contrats
de long terme garantissant une
rémunération qui couvre l'ensemble des
coûts de production de chaque centrale
indépendamment des prix du marché cela
se fait en France pour le photovoltaïque
ou leséoliens par exemple mais alors il
est indispensable d'inciter
financièrement les producteurs à
produire au meilleur moment pour le
système électrique sauf à accepter que
cette incitation financière s'ajoute à
la rémunération garantie par un contrat
long terme nous nous retrouvons alors
face à l'impasse théorique du marché
puisqu'un même prix ne peut pas être ne
peut pas à la fois rémunérer les
installation et inciter à produire au
moment cette inadaptation du marché a
des conséquences sociales économiques et
en terme de capacité à mener la
nécessaire transition énergétique dès
lors l'exploitation du parc par un
acteur centralisé à l'échelle européenne
disposant des informations complètes sur
le parc permettrait d'optimiser
l'utilisation du réseau et la
coordination des centrales en réalité sa
mise en place à l'échelle française
permettrait déjà d'améliorer cette
optimisation sans pour autant remettre
en cause ni la solid ni la solidarité
européenne ni les choix des autres États
membres contrairement aux arguments qui
sont souvent avancés pour dissuader
d'une sortie du marché et pour cause les
interconnexions existaient déjà avant la
mise en place des marchés et j'ajouterai
que la France n'a pas connu d'évolution
majeure des volumes exportés depuis
l'ouverture au marché enfin cette
solution ne peut être mise en œuvre
immédiatement qu'à la condition de
déroger aux règles europées euréenne ce
que plusieurs pays de l'Union européenne
font ou ont déjà fait face au
fonctionnement du
marché sortir du marché n'est donc pas
seulement synonyme d'utar n'est donc non
seulement pas synonyme d'autarc c'est la
solution la plus protectrice pour
l'ensemble des consommateurs avec la
possibilité de rétablir des tarifs
réglementé de vente calculé selon les
coûts de de production et de réseau au
contraire la solution prenée par la
Commission européenne et en cours de
discussion va à l'inverse de cette
solution et libéralise encore un peu
plus le marché en restreignant davantage
encore le recours tarif réglementés de
vente et en encourageant la
décentralisation de la production pour
affaiblir encore un peu plus l'opérateur
historique la deème question de la
composition du mix énergétique n'est pas
nouvelle elle a fait l'objet de
plusieurs débats à l'Assemblée et dans
plusieurs commissions ce n'est pas un
secret à la France insoumise nous
souhaitons sortir le plus rapidement des
énergies fossiles je défends dans le
rapport l'idée d'un mix énergétique basé
à 100 % sur les énergies renouvelable
plusieurs scénarios envisagent la
faisabilité de ce mix negawat à
l'horizon 2035 RTE
le plus souvent à l'horizon 2050 laadème
à l'horizon
2050 en parallèle le recarénage et la
construction de nouvelles centrales
nucléaires représente des sommes
colossales qui pourraient être investies
dans la recherche et la construction de
nouvelles sources de production
d'électricité l'éoliens onshore et
offshore le solaire mais aussi la
géothermie par exemple les énergies Maré
motrices pour prendre un autre exemple
autant de pistes qui sont écartées
systématiquement lorsqu'on les amène
dans le débat public pour compenser
l'intermittence des pardon des énergies
renoulevelable nous pouvons compter sur
l'hydraulique mais aussi sur les
avancées en matière de stockage
d'électricité ou pourquoi pas sur le
développement de de l'hydrogène vert je
porte un regard plus critique que ma
coapporteur sur le rôle du gaz dans la
transition énergétique le gaz est une
énergie fossile donc polluante le gaz
n'est pas non plus produit sur le sol de
l'Union européenne et les quantités de
biogaz sont insuffisantes pour jouer un
rôle quelconque dans la dans la
transition je tiens également à préciser
que lors d'un déplacement que j'ai
effectué aux États-Unis j'ai rencontré
divers euh diverses associations
diverses ONG dans le dans le domaine des
énergies renouvelables et ce qui revient
c'est la critique du fait que le gaz est
le plus souvent issu du gaz de schiste
et ce gaz de schist est extrêmement
polluant et dangereux pour la santé de
ceux qui l'extrait le le taux de cancer
à Freeport au Texas est par exemple deux
fois plus élevé que dans le reste de
l'État l'Europe ne peut pas prétendre
lutter contre le changement climatique
et la protection des droits se tourner
vers de nouvelles formes d'énergie
vertees et ignorer les problématiques
que pose l'extraction du gaz de schist
en conclusion sortir le système
électrique français de la concurrence
est possible et nécessaire pour protéger
l'économie européenne l'économie
française et enclencher les
investissements à la transition
énergétique entravé par la logique de
marché on peut et il faut apporter une
réponse claire au dysfonctionnement du
marché refonder un pôle public de
l'électricité seul capable de répondre
aux enjeux économiques écologiques et
sociaux je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup à toutes les deux pour
votre présentation j'en viiens aux
questions des orateurs de groupe en
commençant par le groupe Renaissance par
Madame Nicole lepet pour 3
minutes merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames les rapporteurs chers collègues
au préalable de ma prise de parole le
groupe Renaissance souhaite féliciter
les rapporteurs pour la qualité de leurs
travaux en effet votre travail va nous
éclairer sur les améliorations à
apporter pour un pour développer une
politique de l'énergie qui corresponde à
nos valeurs nos objectifs c'était
d'illeurs le thème ce matin lors du
petit- déjeuner avec Madame la Ministre
Laurence Baon secrétaire
d'État ma question porte sur le rapport
d'information de sécurité énergétique et
la réforme du marché de l'énergie le
changement climatique et la dégradation
de l'environnement constitue une menace
existentielle pour l'Europe et le monde
pour relever les défis l'Europe a
vocation à transformer notre union en
économie efficace et compétitive dans
l'utilisation de ces ressources dans
votre rapport une des pistes de travail
pour atteindre l'objectif de
décarbonation du mix énergétique et
l'adoption d'une d'une véritable
stratégie européenne de réduction je
dirais intelligente et rationnelle de la
consommation d'énergie pourriez-vous
apporter des précisions sur cette
stratégie et en précisz peut-être les
délais je vous
remercie merci beaucoup la parole est au
rassemblement national et à Thomas
ménager pour 3 minutes merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames les rapporteurs chers
collègues permettez-moi monsieur le
Président avant tout de m'associer à vos
mot en direction du peuple israélien au
nom du groupe rassemblée nationale qui
est ce peuple israélien qui a été
victime d'attaque terroristes ignobles
ces derniers jours pour revenir à
l'objet de notre commission aujourd'hui
vous le savez sur la réforme du marché
européen de l'électricité c'est un
engagement de Marine Le Pen depuis de
nombreuses années et le président de la
République l'annonce depuis désormais 2
ans mais nous voilà malheureusement
aujourd'hui à discuter d'un système dont
on sait tous qu'il est complètement
défaillant madame la rapporteur Boyer
vous exprimez dans le rapport que ce
marché aurait préservé le pouvoir
d'achat et que le système a bien marché
pendant la crise vous venez de le dire
mais chers collègues de la majorité je
vous invite à ouvrir les yeux où est la
protection de nos concitoyens quand
leurs factures ont augmenté deux fois de
15 % puis de 10 % en moins d'un an et
que d'autres hausses sont déjà annoncées
où est la protection de nos artisans nos
boulangers nos bouchers quand ils ont vu
leur factur exploser parfois par 10
multiplié par 10 en plus d'accepter des
hausses de tarifs complètement folles
l'État a déboursé plus de 85000 milliard
d'euros pour limiter l'impact d'un mode
de fixation des prix complètement
dépassé et à la fin qui paye c'est
toujours les Français qui payent ceux
qui bossent comment comme chacun le sait
ici la France est un pays puissant qui
produit l'électricité à bas prix grâce à
une filière nucléaire solide qui a eu
des difficultés mais solide qui
contribue grandement à la sécurité
énergétique du continent malgré un coût
de production d'environ 60 € du mgawh
d'après les chiffres de la creux vous
reprenez dans votre rapport la France
est autage d'un système qui l'oblige à
racheter cette électricité deux à trois
fois plus cher autour de 120 € du mgaw
actuellement les Français ont déjà payé
pour des infrastructures de production
efficaces ils n'ont pas à payer
excusez-moi pour les centrales à gaz
allemandes et pour les erreurs
stratégiques de nos voisins d'outr rein
aucun pays au monde aucun peuple au
monde n'accepterait une telle situation
et l'exception ibérique en Espagne ou
Portugal prouve qu'avec de la volonté
politique et Marine Le Pen là je vous le
dis chers collègues il est possible de
reprendre le contrôle des prix afin de
protéger le pouvoir d'achat de ses
compatriotte et cela sans mettre fin à
l'interconnexion dans votre rapport
mesdames les rapporteurs vous préconisez
de mettre en œuvre un mécanisme
similaire de dérogation temporaire aux
règles du marché européen de
l'électricité avec je cite la
possibilité de recourir à un régime de
crise donc ma première question c'est de
savoir les modalités d'application
concrètees de ce régime de crise proposé
plus globalement le président de la
République et le gouvernement on rétiré
ont réétiré ces derniers jours leur
volonté de réformer ce marché européen
en suivant une proposition formulée par
le rassemblement national depuis
plusieurs années j'ai envie de vous dire
que de temps perdu que de milliard
perdus mais dernières questions seront
donc simples mesdame la rapporteur à
quelle échéance pensez-vous que nous
pourrons aboutir à cette réforme du
marché européen du marché européen
deélectricité excusez-moi pouvez-vous
nous expliquer selon vous pourquoi en
fait le président de la République
Emmanuel Macron n'a pas été capable de
mettre ce sujet sur la table plutôt
notamment quand il a
été à la tête en tant que président
présidence française de l'Union et selon
vous cette volonté de ne pas mettre le
sujet sur le tapis est-elle liée avec
les réticences exprimées par l'Allemagne
qui tire largement profit de ce marché
européen je vous remercie merci beaucoup
la parole est à Gabriel Amar pour le
groupe de la France et pour 3
minutes merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames les rapporteurs le marché
européen de l'énergie est incapable
d'assurer une stabilité des prix de
l'électricité pour les entreprises comme
pour les
particuliers d'après l'INC le prix
annuel moyen du mgaw a augmenté de 45 %
en 2022 pour atteindre 113 € après déjà
une hausse de 21 % l'année précédente le
prix du mgaw a ainsi presque doublé
depuis 20 ans depuis 2020 pardon où il
atteignait 64 €. de Tell Hauses des prix
ont des conséquences majeures sur notre
économie et sur le niveau de vie de nos
concitoyens ces hausses de prix se
répercutent dans le prix des biens et
services et contribuent à alimenter la
spirale inflationniste qui ne nous lâche
plus depuis bientôt 2 ans nos
concitoyens sont confrontés dans ma
circonscription comme dans le reste de
la France à des facture d'électricité
exorbitante les témoignages d'artisans
de commerçants particulièrement de
boulanger pris à la gorge ne cessent de
se multiplié depuis plusieurs mois
l'association des maires de France et
l'ensemble des collectivités appelle au
retour des tarifs réglementés comme le
rappelle la Cour des comptes dans son
rapport de 2022 sur l'organisation des
marchés de l'électricité ceux qui ont
mis en œuvre la libéralisation du marché
de l'électricité dans les années 90
pensait que le libre jeu de la
concurrence serait le plus à même de
satisfaire la demande énergétique au
moindre coût près de 30 ans après il est
certain que ces gens soit avaient tort
soit
mentaient en fixant le prix de
l'électricité sur le coût de production
de la centrale la plus chère en Europe
nous nous condamnons à nous aligner sur
le coût du gaz dont les prix sont très
volatile éloigné du coût de production
de l'électricité se référer à ce prix du
marché n'a aucun intérêt ni pour la
rémunération des producteurs ni pour la
tarification des consommateurs il est
plus qu'urgent de revenir à des tarifs
réglementés calculés sur le coût de
production avec une part permettant
d'investir sérieusement dans la
planification écologique le coût de
production de l'électricité en France
étant bien inférieur à celui du marché
européen nous soulagerions ainsi le
porte-monnaie de millions de personnes
et de petites entreprises ainsi que le
budget des collectivités locales dans le
même temps le producteur bénéficiera
d'une visibilité à long terme et d'une
stabilité des prix voilà la position de
mon groupe la France insoumise je vous
remercie merci beaucoup la parole est à
Frédéric petit pour le groupe démocrate
c'est pour 3
minutes merci monsieur le
Président merci pour votre rapport c'est
toujours intéressant d'avoir un rapport
contradictoire et un rapport où on pose
on pose les différences et les et les et
les contrad que nous portons au nom du
peuple français tous autant que nous
sommes ici je voudrais revenir moi sur
plutôt sur le l'aspect souveraineté que
l'aspect que l'aspect prix et crise des
prix qui ne me semble pas dans des
temporalités identiques d'abord je
voudrais revenir sur un certain nombre
de de de
précision qui me paraissent importante à
partager avec l'ensemble de mes
collègues d'abord la géothermie oui
évidemment la géothermie ne fait pas
d'électricité toute seule je le rappelle
quand même la géothermie per permet de
de est une est une source quasiment
inépuisable très intéressante mais vous
ne faites pas tourner une turbine
uniquement avec la géothermie vous
économiser dans ce que vous faites mais
il vous il vous faudra autre chose donc
la géothermie peut permettre de résoudre
par exemple l'énorme quantité d'énergie
que nous gaspills dans les dans les
locaux avec des réseaux de chaleur et
cetera mais il y a une petite j'ai senti
une petite confusion sur géothermie
électricité puis je rappelle aussi que
le CO2 n'est pas un polluant il faut
savoir ce qu'on dit le extraire extraire
du gaz de schiste c'est polluant
produire de du CO2 ce n'est pas polluant
ça fait de l'effet de serre c'est c'est
il faut il faut le contrôler mais
heureusement qu'on produit un petit peu
de CO2 pour que les arbres puissent
vivre donc il faut il faut utiliser les
bons mots surtout quand on est regardé
par la par la France je voudrais revenir
maintenant sur deux choses madame enfin
vous avez présenté dans votre rapport de
manière assez consensuelle
l'idée d'un d'une centralisation de la
gestion des réseaux je suis assez
surpris d'abord parce qu'elle existe en
France et heureusement sinon sinon les
lampes qui viennent de s'éteindre 4000
fois pendant que je parle n'auraient pas
serait éteintte voilà les réseaux les
réseaux sont gérés de manière
centralisée en France c'est un c'est un
dispositif qui existe pas très loin de
Paris et tous les réseaux sont gérés de
façon centralisée il y a des pays où le
réseau ne s'est pas centralisé comme
l'Allemagne mais tous les réseaux sont
sont géré de manière centralisée dès
aujourd'hui sinon ça marche pas par
contre là où je je sens aussi une une
enfin du vocabulaire qu'il faut préciser
les interconnexions ce n'est pas une
gestion centralisée européenne des
réseaux ça fait même plutôt la pagaille
hein donc je suis moi depuis très
longtemps je considère effectivement que
nous devrions progresser sur une gestion
européenne des réseaux nous l'avons fait
pour des mauvaises raisons il y a 20 ans
il y a 30 ans comme vient de le rappeler
un de mes collègues mais maintenant il
faudrait avancer là-dedans mais ça
commencera d'abord par des
investissements d'abord par des
investissements parce que aujourd'hui le
réseau allemand est ne peut pas aider le
réseau européen à travailler voilà et
puis je voudrais rappeler aussi à
certains collègues que c'est pas le
contribuable qui paye l'électricité
c'est le consommateur il faut aussi
faire attention à ce qu'on dit c'est le
consommateur français qui a payé qui a
payé les investissements et enfin je ne
suis pas d'accord avec le
scénario tous les scénarios à 100 %
renouvelables en 2050 ne sont pas
complets je rappelle à mes collègues
qu'ils imposent des recherches dont nous
n'avons pas les résultats aujourd'hui
merci merci beaucoup monsieur petit la
parole est à Marietta caramandi pour le
groupe socialiste et pour 3
minutes voilà merci monsieur le
Président chers collègu je souhaite tout
d'abord remercier les les deux collègues
rapporteurs pour le projet qu'elles nous
ont présenté et qui est d'une grande
actualité bien sûr et importance
chagissant de la sécurité énergétique et
la réforme du marché de l'électricité ce
sont évidemment donc les recommandations
faites et les points de sortie envisagé
qui nous intéresse et donc il y a deux
versions un peu différentes de ce qui
app paraît adapté à la situation
actuelle le projet de directive approuvé
par le Parlement qui relève
considérablement les objectifs de
l'Union européenne initialement prévu en
en matière d'énergie renouvelable en
exigeant que
42,5 % de l'énergie de l'Union
européenne soit d'origine renouvelable
d'ici 2030 et puis la part des énergies
renouvelables dans le bouquet
énergétique de lieu euh qui se lève
actuellement à 22,1 % et qui signifie
qu'il faudra justement pratiquement
doubler cette part d'ici 2030
principalement en augmentant la capacité
de de production d'énergie éolienne et
solaire alors la France a une dérogation
permettant au pays disposant d'un d'un
bouquet d'électricité décbonés tel que
le nucléaire de satisfaire à des exigen
moindre en matière d'hydrogène
renouvelable et plusieurs États ont fait
valoir que cela amoindrirait le
développement des énergies renouvelables
Solair éolien il y a donc une difficulté
à débrancher le système énergétique
actuel et les avantages longtemps donnés
sur la supériorité du système français
de son nucléaire ont été mis à mal ces
dernières années donc de façon donc
constructive je pense que nous pourrions
soutenir aussi trois éléments la
création donc d'une communauté d'experts
européen sur le coût de la
décarbonisation et la prise en compte
des effets les coûts du nuclé sur la
biodiversité et la santé et non
seulement au niveau des déchets ça fait
partie d'une proposition qui a été faite
précédemment lors de la taxonomie que
nous avions ici examiné la détermination
aussi consensuelle également de
ressources énergétiques durables
permettant de mieux articuler la
décarbonisation énergie réelle
réellement renouvelable et le troisème
aspect l'enjeu du traitement des
filières industrielles des énergies
puisse être un élément de réflexion et
d'évaluation pris en compte dans les
analyses alors une question que je
souhaiterais vous poser le prix de
l'énergie l'énergie et de la sécurité
deprovisionnement comment nos principaux
voisins européens aujourd'hui voient-ils
l'évolution pour leurs consommateurs et
leur souveraineté ça n permettrait de
d'avoir un point de positionnement des
autres États merci beaucoup merci la
parole est à Félicie gérrard pour le
groupe
horizon merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames les rapporteurs nous examinons
aujourd'hui votre rapport sur la urité
énergétique et sur la réforme du marché
de l'énergie bien évidemment je vous
remercie pour ce travail qui permet
d'avoir une vision sur l'ensemble des
réformes touchant au marché de
l'électricité comme vous l'avez rappelé
comme l'indique la nouvelle directive
sur les énergies renouvelables et comme
l'indique le plan REpower eu plan
proposé par la Commission européenne en
mai 2022 pour économiser l'énergie
produire de l'énergie propres et
diversifier nos approvisionnements
énergétiques il s'agit de développer
massivement les énergies renouvelable
pour atteindre nos objectifs de
réduction des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre de 55 % à l'horizon 2030 mais
cela ne peut se faire au dépend des
installations nucléaires existantes qui
garantissent une énergie décarbonée et
pilotable tout aussi essentiel pour
préserver notre souveraineté
énergétique c'est sur ce point que je
souhaiterais concentrer mon intervention
vous l'avez souligné dans votre rapport
la position de la Commission européenne
sur le sujet ne va pas dans le sens de
l'intégration du nucléaire dans le mix
puisqu'il est le grand absent du plan
fit
for55 paquet de 13 proposition
législative publiée par la Commission
européenne en juillet 2021 et proposant
des actions concrètes pour accomplir les
objectifs de l'Union européenne de
réduction des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre de 55 % au moins en 2030 par
rapport à
1990 mes questions sont donc simples
pensez-vous que l'énergie nucléaire est
essentielle à l'autonomie stratégique de
le de l'Europe en manière en matière
énergétique et si oui comment convaincre
nos homologues et particulièrement nos
amis allemands d'aller dans ce sens je
vous
remercie merci et enfin André chassig
pour le groupe GDR pour 3
minutes merci j'aurais quatre remarques
tout en saluant l'excellent travail des
rapporteurs la première la réforme d
structurelle du marché européen de
l'électricité conduite par la Commission
européenne ne constitue qu'un
approfondissement des outils de marché
pour essayer de Pier les défaillances du
marché si cher aux adeptes du
néolibéralisme les nouvelles règles ne
s'attaquent pas au fond du problème qui
est l'indispensable
décorrélation des prix de l'électricité
de celui des combustibles fossiles et du
gaz aucune garantie sérieuse n'est
apportée sur ce point ce doit être la
première ligne rouge de la France dans
cette réforme deuxième remarque il n'est
pas acceptable que cette réforme se
transforme en outil déguisé pour couvrir
des choix d'investissement passés qui
ont contribué à accroître notre
dépendance au fossiles les Européens et
les Français n'ont pas à compenser les
amains énergétiques et géopolitiques de
l'Allemagne comme d'autres partenaires
européens qui sont littéralement vrés
dans la frénésie gazière c'est une
deuxième ligne rouge 3isème remarque la
priorité en terme d'investissement doit
être donné au renforcement des capacités
des États à sécuriser maîtriser
décarboner leur propre système
électrique à ce titre l'incontournable
énergie nucléaire doit impérativement
pouvoir bénéficier des mêmes mesures de
soutien que les énergies renouvelables
en particulier pour les outils de
financement de long terme qui pourrait
être misise en place pour favoriser la
transition énergétique et la neutralité
carbone nous avons impérativement besoin
de sécuriser les outils de production
décarbonés et surtout pilotable c'est
une troisème ligne rouge sur laquelle la
France ne peut transiger 4e remarque
la France doit définir elle-même au plus
vite les modalités les plus efficaces
pour répondre aux enjeux de sa propre
souveraineté énergétique sans attendre
que la commission ou les pressions
d'autres États et des requins de la
rente électrique ne dicte leurs
conditions le travail d'analyse et de
proposition parlementaires n'a jamais
été aussi fourni commission d'enquête
parlementaire sur la perte de
souveraineté et d'indépendance
énergétique de la France d'information
sénatorial sur les conditions
d'utilisation de l'arine le rapport
d'information qui nous est présenté
aujourd'hui et j'en passe il est temps
de sortir du scandale d'état de laarè
avec une sécurisation des
investissements durables desdf un
renforcement des sanctions voir
l'interdiction
d'acticité des opérateurs opportunistes
sans foisillois pour conclure deux
questions la priorité doit-elle de
maintenir artificiellement des
opérateurs commerciaux qui spéculent sur
le dos des usagers DF ou de reconstruire
un vrai service public unifié de
l'électricité autour des DF désormais
renationalisé deème question la priorité
doit-elle être d'entretenir une
concurrence factice et la spéculation
sur la rente électrique ou d'assurer des
prix réglementés pour tous couvrant les
vrais coûts de production d'df merci
beaucoup monsieur chassigne je crois que
nous avons terminé avec les orateurs de
groupe mesdames vous avez la parole pour
répondre à toutes ces
questions
merci merci chers collègues pour ces
pour ces échanges et ces questions fort
intéressantes donc en ce qui concerne la
question de Madame le P sur la stratégie
de la sobriété donc effectivement
l'objectif de la
directive alors quand on parle en
premier on a on a pour se préparer c'est
un petit peu plus long que quand on
parle en second euh sur l'objectif de la
directive j'ai perdu le fil de mes idées
donc on va y
arriver enfin bon il y a une directive
européenne sur l'objectif de 11 donc qui
a une un objectif de diminuer de 11,7 %
la consommation finale d'énergie à
l'horizon 2030 donc chaque État aura
évidemment le le le plein exercice de
pouvoir le soumettre à la Commission et
de pouvoir le le prendre en sa
possession en ce qui concerne le le la
réponse à
Monsieur
ménager donc vous nous avez dit
que ça avait coûté enfin toutes les
mesures de protection avaient coûté 85
milliards d'euros moi j'ai pas tout à
fait ces chiffres
là je n'ai pas tout à fait ces chiffres
là puisque l'aide au consommateur pour
2022 en ce qui concerne le gaz a été de
6,7 million d'euros pour l'électricité
de 18,2 milliards d'euros pour 2023 le
gaz 2 2,3 milliards d'urosélectricité
29,3 milliards d'euros quand on fait le
total de tout cela en 2022 ça ça nous a
coûté à peu près 43 milliards et en 2023
45 milliards effectivement ça ça ça ça
ça se rapproche des 85 milliards mais en
même temps le
ce qui a été le choix du gouvernement a
été de protéger les Français de protéger
tous les français si vous on avez
appliqué votre choix vos politiques bien
sûr une baisse de la TVA et bien nous
n'aurions pas protégé tous les Français
nous aurions protégé les fournisseurs
donc je pense qu'il était quand même
plus important et plus intéressant et
plus judicieux de protéger tous les
Français tous les Français sans
condition de baisse de consommation et
de protéger davantage les plus les plus
les les personnes les plus en précarité
avec le chèque énergie donc chacun a sa
politique mais je pense que il est
difficile de dire que le gouvernement
français à l'époque n'a pas protégé les
Français et qui a multiplié la enfin
qu'il a permis la multiplication par 10
des
factures nous sommes l'état européen qui
a été quasiment le plus protecteur pour
le pouvoir d'achat des Français donc il
est difficile d'admettre et d'entendre
que le contrôle des prix n'a pas été
fait et justement il a il y a eu une une
moindre augmentation de l'inflation par
rapport à toutes les mesures
gouvernementales qui ont été prises et
non seulement sur l'énergie mais aussi
surt le l'inflation sur tous les
produits hors énergie donc nous nous
avons préservé l'inflation nous avons
préservé le pouvoir d'achat des Français
et nous continuons à le préserver euh en
ce qui concerne le futur de la
protection des consommateurs et bien
nous souhaitons effectivement que les
contrats à long terme les P les PP et
les CFD permettent de garantir les prix
sur plusieurs années donc c'est pour ça
que nous sommes et que le gouvernement
et que la ministre de la transition
énergétique travaille au niveau de
l'Europe pour pouvoir
effectivement consolider ces contrats à
long terme donc on nous vous une
question a été posée concernant le
calendrier alors il y a un conseil qui
se déroulera le 17 octobre si il y a une
un accord dans ce conseil et bien il y
aura un déclenchement de de la trilogie
à partir du 19 octobre au matin donc ce
qui veut dire que l'envie et la volonté
de tout le monde c'est d'aller très vite
justement pour pouvoir mettre en place
des mesures qui permettront de protéger
les consommateurs de protéger
l'approvisionnement de nos de nos de de
notre énergie et en même temps de
pouvoir mettre en place des mesures qui
permettront de ne pas avoir à ajuster en
dernière minute des des budgets des des
des budgets concernant euh les États et
notamment l'état de la France euh en ce
qui concerne les contrats pour la
différence euh la France veut que ces
contrats veut uniform veut que ces
contrats soient uniformes alors que
d'autres pays souhaitent que enfin que
la redistribution pardon des contrats
soient uniformes et qu'ell soit
redistribué à tout le monde c'est-à-dire
particulier et industrie et industrie en
ce qui concerne concerne certains pays
je pense notamment à l'Allemagne il y a
un désaccord puisque l'Allemagne
souhaiterait pouvoir avoir le choix de
la
redistribution des des recettes par
rapport à ces contrats sur la différence
ce qui mettrait en danger et en périle
notre économie puisque nous aurions une
distorsion de concurrence et un manque
de compétitivité donc je pense que la
France est est présente bien présente
dans ces dans dans les négociations et
que la ministre de la transition
écologique euh énergétique pardon et là
et préserve tous les intérêts de la
France
euh sur le régime de crise aussi
euh vous nous avez posé une question sur
le régime de crise c'est dans la
proposition du règlement en cas
d'envoler des prix on peut recourir à
des tarifs réglementés et notre
recommandation madame IOL et moi-même
c'est de faire en sorte que chaque État
puisse déclencher ce régime de crise et
pas seulement que ce soit la commission
qui soit qui ait la main sur ce
déclenchement euh ce qui nous serait
beaucoup plus protecteur concernant nos
voilà ce ce déclenchement des des des
régimes de crise
euh alors en ce qui concerne la question
de Monsieur Frédéric petit euh sur la
géothermie donc il y a un rapport en
cours au Parlement européen euh et ce
rapport
euh
est en train de d'être étudié avec
Marine mesure sur les réseaux et les
investissements bien sûr qu'il faut
investir fortement sur les sur les
réseaux il faut rester dans
l'intercnexion bien évidemment et il
paraît compliqué de vouloir un sortir du
marché et en même temps être rester dans
cette interconnexion donc je pense que
l'idée c'est de rester dans l'Europe et
de rester dans la course de l'Europe et
rester dans la course de l'Europe ça
veut dire que il faut prendre part aux
négociations concernant les réformes sur
le marché énergétique et le les réformes
du sur le marché de l'électricité et en
même temps effectivement renforcer notre
notre réseau de transport nous avons eu
de nombreux échanges avec les personnes
que nous avonsudné puisque c'était quand
même un sujet qui ressortait souvent
dans les discussions cette
interconnexion ce renforcement des
réseaux on le voit bien au niveau
national notamment dans nos territoires
ruraux mais aussi au niveau européen
mais ce qu'on peut dire aussi c'est que
ce réseau ce réseau interconnecté a
aussi permis durant la crise de pouvoir
garder l'approvisionnement et de pouvoir
à ce que tous les Français tous les
toutes les étatsmembres de l'Union
européenne puissent être approvisionné
au niveau de
l'énergie voilà je donc ça c'était pour
Monsieur petit donc pour Monsieur Caram
Mandi mi pardon comment donc votre
question c'était comment voit on voit
les autres pays car caramani pardon
excusez-moi je m'excuse je vous ai
écorcher votre nom comment voit les
autres pays d'approvisionnement
énergétique alors comment on voit les
autres pays l'approvisionnement
énergétique alors on a deux clubs on a
les amis du nucléaire dont nous nous
faisons partie et nous avons aussi si
les amines du renouvelable dont la
France est aussi membre donc on a des
fortes divergences entre l'Allemagne et
la France sur le sujet un sujet de
compétitivité de
l'économie un sujet de compétitivité
concernant l'économie française puisque
comme je viens de vous le dire
l'Allemagne souhaite faire avoir une
redistribution notamment des contrats à
long terme not et d'avoir le choix de sa
redistribution pour éventuellement
redistribuer que sur son économie alors
alors que nous nous vous prenons le
choix de pouvoir redistribuer au niveau
de tous les consommateurs particuliers
entreprise et collectivité
territoriale concernant la question de
Monsieur de Madame Gérard
euh comment convaincre que le est une
solution alors oui comment on peut
convaincre que le nucléaire est une
solution
euh nous souhaitons nous dans notre re
mix énergétique et pour atteindre les
objectifs de l'Union européenne et que
la France aussi s'est fixé de pouvoir
effectivement avoir une une solution de
production un moyen de production qui
permette d'avoir un mix énergétique
stable qui permettent de garantir un
approvisionnement de de de notre énergie
et de notre électricité et donc les le
nucléaire et nous l'avons même s'il y a
eu des soucis il faut le reconnaître au
niveau en en automne 2022 concernant
effectivement la les les la la corrosion
les corrosions sous contrainte des des
réacteurs nucléaires mais nous avons
bien vu que euh nous avons pu tenir
aussi grâce à notre énergie euh
nucléaire euh l'énergie nucléaire est
une neutralis une une une énergie bac
carbone euh qui a qui qui est euh on va
dire euh peu coûteuse et qui nous permet
d'avoir une production stable par
rapport à toutes à par exemple à des
énergies comme les énergie renouvelable
dont on sait très bien qui qu'elles sont
soumises à aux aléas climatiques moi je
pense aussi à l'hydroélectricité en
étant député de territoire de montagne
elle aussi là aussi nous avons une
électricité qui permet aussi d'avoir une
stabilité dans la production et en même
temps d'avoir une comment dire un
stockage de de de de l'électricité
euh pour l'instant c'est la seule qui
permet d'avoir un stockage de
l'électricité euh avec de si grandes
capacités par rapport aux autres
énergies
renouvelables donc la France aussi alors
on peut regretter effectivement que le
que le le nucléaire n'a jamais n''est
jamais été dans les discussions de
l'Union européenne concernant les
directives et notamment dans les textes
du fit for fit for for5 et bien
évidemment je pense
que actuellement les discussions se font
aussi au niveau de
la de la redistribution pour les
investissements en ce qui concerne euh
les nouvelles comment dire les
nouvelles les nouveaux investissements
qui pourra être fait pour la les
nouvelles capacités de production
d'électricité et les discussions se font
aussi au niveau du Conseil concernant la
la possibilité de financer des les
investissements sur les anciennes
centrales pour les les remettre à niveau
de manière à ce que on puisse avoir de
nouvelles capacités de production
d'électricité
enfin je
terminerai par la question de
Monsieur
chass concernant
[Musique]
les je sais plus ce que cétait
ou oui la sortie du oui excusez-moi
c'était la la sortie du marché donc
concernant la sortie du marché
bien je pense que que je viens de déjà
de le dire la sortie du marché c'est
une ENF sortir du marché dans un quand
on fait partie de l'Union européenne du
sortir du marché de de l'énergie quand
on est dans l'Union européenne quand on
fait un quand on fait partie d'un État
membre et que c'est quand même
l'histoire de l'Union
européenne de le voilà je pense queon
est dans une situation où si on sortait
du marché euh et si on se retrouvait
dans une crise comme nous avons vécu en
automne 2022 euh comment pourrions-nous
sortir la France comment pourrions-nous
préserver notre approvisionnement
comment pourrions-nous nous préserver
concernant notre énergie euh bien sûr
que on peut avoir les rêves de il y a
quelques années maintenant ou quelques
décennies mais euh il il paraît les les
les temps ont changé tout a
évolué le marché a évolué nous sommes
dans un marché de l'Union européenne
nous avons nous travaillons avec nos
partenaires nous voyons bien que avec
malheureusement l'actualité qui nous
entoure et qui qui qui malheureusement
est désastreuse actuellement si nous ne
restions pas unis sur des politique
régalienne telle que l'énergie euh
sortir la France du marché
européen pour rester en autarciie pour
ne plus avoir de de
d'interconnexion entre les différents
pays de l'Union européenne je pense que
ça serait peut-être quelque chose qui
peut satisfaire certains d'entre nous
mais qui ne protégeraiit pas les
Français qui ne protégeraient pas de
l'approvisionnement en énergie et qui au
bout du compte peut-être nous coûterait
peut-être certainement plus cher que ce
que ça nous
rapporterait merci
[Musique]
beaucoup alors à mon tour de d'apporter
des éléments de réponse qui seront
souvent différents des éléments de
réponse qui viennent d'être donnés par
par ma coapporteur mais qui font partie
de toute façon des échanges
complémentaires qu'il y a et des
contenus complémentaires qu'il y a dans
ce rapport sur la trajectoire de
réduction de consommation d'énergie bon
on peut estimer qu'une réduction de 11,7
% de la consommation par rapport à 2030
on peut aussi être plus ambitieux je
donne des des exemples qui ont été
explorés notamment dans les différents
débats qu'on a eu à l'Assemblée sur la
rénovation énergétique du bâti qui avait
été chiffré qui avait été adopté à
hauteur de 12 milliards d'euros sur la
politique de transport qui aujourd'hui
est largement insuffisante on avait
également une proposition d'amendement
qui avait été adoptée avant que le PLF
soit finalement repassé par une une
autre méthode qui était de 3 milliards
d'euros par ailleurs bon je précise que
les les investissements des des
industriels pour électrifier les usages
ça passe par une visibilité des prix et
que s'ils n'ont pas cette visibilité là
ce n'est pas incitatif donc ça revient à
dire que il faut une stabilité des prix
et que la capacité de tous les
consommateurs comme des producteurs à
investir en faveur de la réduction de la
de la tion en faveur de la
décarbonation passe par cette visibilité
des prix là ensuite donc bon je vais
faire peut-être par thème mais il y
avait plusieurs plusieurs allusions au à
la nécessité bon notamment parce qu'il
faut stabiliser les prix de revenir à un
tarif
réglementé j'appuie notamment ce qu'a
dit Monsieur har à ce
sujet c'est ce qu'on porte notamment à
la France insoumise he le retour à un
tarif réglementé euh et euh et c'est une
nécessité pour couvrir les trois aspects
que j'ai mis en avant recouvrement des
coûts de production visibilité équité de
traitement entre les consommateurs moi
je peux pas dire que que la les les
mécanismes de protection qui ont été mis
en en place en France sont suffisants
sont satisfaisant dans la mesure où
encore aujourd'hui il y a des boulangers
qui mettent la clé sous la porte ou des
industries
délocalise où des consommatrices et des
consommateurs alertent les députés
notamment de la hausse de leur facture
et donc tout ça montre quand même que on
peut faire largement mieux mais pour ça
ça nécessite d'arbitrer de manière
économique de manière écologique de
manière sociale il y a des questions
qu'il faut se poser notamment sur la
manière dont on finance cela et ce sont
ces questionslà en fait qu'il faut
trancher par un débat public
euh
ensuite
oui je je remercie monsieur le
professeur petit pour les les
corrections de vocabulaire les
ajustements les
reprécisions sur la
géothermie donc effectivement madame
mesure est en charge d'un d'un d'un
travail sur ce sujet-là ce qu'on peut
dire c'est que en fait cette filière a
manqué d'investissement et donc parce
que ça a été jugé notamment pas assez
rentable par les acteurs privés et donc
ça va dans le sens de dire que et bien
si on veut pouvoir connaître la
faisabilité la rentabilité et bien il
faut investir mais ça nécessite un choix
politique euh madame mesure elle a été
nommé euh comment on dit pour le groupe
de Left elle a été nommée au rapporteur
sur le déploiement de la géothermie en
Europe très exactement
h alors il y a eu plusieurs questions
sur comment euh comment on on coordonne
l'action avec les les États-membres avec
l'Allemagne notamment c'est clair qu'il
y a il y a des écarts il y a des euh des
points de vue différents et puis il n'y
a pas les mêmes choix qui sont faits en
fait entre les différents États-membres
de l'Union européenne et notamment la
critique du marché euh elle s'étend à
plusieurs états et en fait la défense du
marché plutôt il faut dire se resserre
de plus en plus autour de l'Allemagne du
choix du gouvernement français et de
certains autres pays pour autant les
dysfonctionnements sont soulignés dans
plusieurs dans plusieurs pays par
ailleurs le je disais tout à l'heure que
les interconnexions en fait elles sont
elles existaient déjà avant le passage
au marché et que donc ce n'est pas
comment dire ce ne serait pas
euh complètement aventureux que le la la
France choisisse un autre fonctionnement
puisque par exemple EDF fonctionnait
déjà en interconnexion avec d'autres
pays européens en fait c'est
l'exploitant public français qui
interviendrait comme n'importe quel
acteur dans ce système d'organisation
européen les volumes d'échange
d'électricité continueraient à être payé
au prix de marché mais l'impact d'une
solution avec un pilotage public serait
une amélioration du programme d'appel
français et donc européen par le
regroupement de producteurs multiples au
sein d'un même acteur public et donc ça
permettrait une meilleure coordination
en fait à l'échelle française et puis on
peut espérer à l'échelle européenne
euh autre ouais je suis obligée de dire
quand même y compris parce que on
voudrait comme ça persuader d'autres
pays d'utiliser le nucléaire bon déjà
c'est un débat il faut enfin je veux
dire même en France ce débat n'est pas
tranché on peut pas ignorer que il y a
quand même une voix qui s'élève pour
dire que il est temps de passer à à une
autre énergie et qui bon ça ne nous
empêche pas d'ailleurs de souligner le
euh la souveraineté qui a permis
d'atteindre le nucléaire de dire que ça
a été une
euh une une force de production
essentielle pour le redéveloppement de
l'économie française mais que si on a
été capable de produire de de d'entrer
justement dans une force aussi dynamique
on doit être capable aussi d'inventer
autre chose par ailleurs on peut pas
balayer d'un revers de main les débats
qui existent sur le la façon dont on
traite les déchets nucléaires personne
ne sait traiter les déchets nucléaires
personne ne sait comment on fait avec
les déchets nucléaires aucun pays du
monde personne n'a envie de vivre il
qu'avoir les les mobilisations qu'il y a
à Bur quand même personne n'a envie de
vivre avec des déchets nucléaires sous
son sol moi la première j'en ai pas
envie et donc ça on peut pas l'écarter
d'un revers de la main ça veut dire que
en responsabilité il faut savoir
proposer d'autres solutions et que on
est on n'est pas obligé de rester fermé
dans un modèle qui a été puissant qui a
été fort qui a fait son efficacité mais
qui suscite des critiques et notamment
aussi parce que l'insécurité nucléaire
même si elle est rare ce n'est pas la la
la rareté qui doit justifier le fait que
on on on balaye de la main comme ça les
les la nécessité de passer à autre chose
un accident nucléaire c'est ça ça
produit d'énormes dégâts et bon on peut
pas dire ça se produira que dans les
autres pays où ça s'est produit au Japon
en Russie parce que il y a eu des
défauts de pilotage ou je sais pas quoi
on peut pas balayer comme ça d'un revers
de la main
euh bon et ensuite je crois que je crois
que ça croise un peu ce que j'ai déjà
dit je vérifie quand même je m'étais
noté plein de choses et évidemment
j'aurais jamais le temps de tout
développer en fait peut-être comme mot
de conclusion sur la remise en question
du du marché sur la sortie du
marché on je voudrais quand même
souligner qu'à la France insoumise nous
sommes les seuls à proposer des
scénarios alternatifs à à donner des des
des pistes à émettre des critiques mais
que à la fois dans toutes les auditions
que nous avons faites à la fois dans
même ce qui a été mis en avant ici il
n'y a jamais d'argumentation en fait sur
pourquoi il faut rester dans le marché
il y a jamais d'arguments solide SR mais
parce que ça apporterait des solutions
justement bah sur l'augmentation des
factures en fait bon bah on s'en lave
les mains quoi euh on peut pas rester
face à ce constat résigner et puis
continuer et poursuivre comme si de rien
éétait il en va quand même de la vie de
concitoyenne et concitoyens qui peuvent
pas payer leur factur et donc bon bah
nous avons l'impression de faire face à
une idéologie un peu aveugle et dans le
déniis de ce qui se passe nous proposons
autre chose il n'y a jamais de solutions
concrètes qui sont apporté ou de de
contrearguments solides ou voilà qui
sont apportés à ce que nous on
développe merci beaucoup alors il reste
quatre demandes de questions je vous
demandis d'être bref parce qu'il y a
encore un autre rapport derrière et puis
il y a la séance
donc non très bien alors une question à
moi et Madame
mche est-ce que vous pouvez le faire en
une minute s'il vous plaît merci
beaucoup
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames les
rapporteurs chers collègues ce rapport
ressemble à un trop timide commencement
de prise de conscience que le marché de
l'électricité tel qu'il est conçu par
l'Union européenne est incohérent et
s'adosse principalement aux capacités de
production de la France tout en lui
nuisant et en nuuisant par la même aux
Français je partage nombre de réserves
que mesdames les rapporteurs apportent
vis-à-vis de l'accès réglementé
électricité nucléaire historique
laarenne notamment cependant les
perspectives envisagées par l'Union
européenne sont frappées par une
politique obsessionnelle du recours à
l'accélération du développement de
l'énergie produite par les
aérogénérateurs industriels de
production intermittente d'électricité à
l'horizon 2050 page 32 du rapport ma
question est donc double quels sont les
engagements qui peuvent qui peuvent être
pris pour stopper le mécanisme actuel de
l'arène et l'orienter vers l'intérêt de
la France et des Français et avez-vous
vous l'intention d'amender cette
obsession pour le recours aux
installations d'éoliennne intermittente
et nuisible à une distribution stable
d'électricité sans insister sur les
nombreuses dégradations qu'ell
produisent merci merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup d'avoir tenu la minute Frédéric
petit pour une minute
oui merci monsieur le Président je je je
je je voulais simplement m'élever contre
le le terme qui a été utilisé je suis un
député qui a une expérience comme vous
avez une expérience je vous respecte
vous
je je sur le sur
le je ne suis pas un professeur ici je
suis pas un professeur ici oui mais
c'est évitons les les provocations
inutiles on a un débat ça s'adresse à
vous en l'occurrence madame OL parce que
vous l'avez qualifié de professeur alors
que le débat était plutôt apaisé donc je
vous demanderai de respecter vos
collègues et et Frédéric petit et
Frédéric petit répond assez non mais je
vous le dis ça se passe non non il l'a
pas traité d'idiote à aucun moment il a
utilisé le mot d'idiote madame Chikirou
donc je vous demand simplement à ce que
les uns et les autres se respectent et
c'est tout je demande à ce que les uns
et les autres se respectent merci
Monsieur petit vous avez la parole se
monsieur petit à la parole oui donc sur
le je je j'ai dit tout à l'heure et je
le répète pour pour l'ensemble de mes
collègues j'étais je travaille dans dans
ce métier là et j'étais contre la la
séparation la la l'arrivée du marché sur
les réseaux moi j'étais un gestionnaire
de réseau c'est effectivement ça a posé
d'énormes problèmes on l'a fait pour de
mauvaises raison il y a 30 ans
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas à la fois
demander comme vous l'avez très
justement demandé madame la rapporteur
et vous l'avez très justement expliqué
au début de votre intervention appeler à
une gestion centralisée européenne des
réseau et à la fois refuser que sur ces
réseaux qui vont être centralisés à 1/e
de seconde je vous rappelle c'est 1/e de
secondes hein chaque 50e de secondes on
ne peut pas à la fois demander ça et à
la fois demander que dans chaque endroit
de ces réseaux on aura un mécanisme de
prix qui sera complètement indépendant
et complètement autonome forcément le
fait de dire je veux des plus que des
interconnexions je veux une gestion du
réseau intelligente au niveau européen
nous en avons besoin je suis un un
partisan depuis des années de cette de
cette évolution nécessite que nous ayons
des mécanismes de prix commun merci
beaucoup la parole est à Madame France
Gamet pour une minute oh accordez-moi de
pour une minute madame la député on ce
matin pour venir vous voir ça fait
plaisir voy alors on va parler de ce
système parasitaire qui effectivement
comme vous l'avez très bien dit Madame
osiol ne produit pas un seul kilwh mais
qui oblige DF avant son électricité
pratiquement à perte via laaren je
voudrais quand même rappeler deux
petites choses la première c'est que les
failles du marché européen de l'énergie
nont été n'ont pas été révélés par la la
crise russo-ukrainienne en une décennie
les prix de l'électricité avaient déjà
augmenté de 50 %. dans cette réforme
rien rien n'est dit pour remettre en
cause la mécanisme de fixation des des
prix euh et pour cause parce que Berlin
s'y oppose aucune possibilité non plus
de mettre fin à la concurrence
totalement artificielle et faussée et
pour cause euh la Commission de
Bruxelles s'y oppose je voudrais
rappeler deux choses euh premièrement
euh comme par rapport à ce que vous avez
dit tout à l'heure la réforme du marché
et l'intégration électrique n'ont
absolument rien à voir l'une est
politique et l'autre est logistique
deuxièmement pour réviser le mécanisme
de fixation des prix il faut payer le
vrai prix et les Français ne paient pas
le vrai prix troisièmement et j'en
termine je vous rappelle simplement que
pour défendre réellement nos intérêts
ceux de la France et des Français il
faudrait déjà a commencer par le
défendre à l'Europe renu tous les tous
les tous les partis politiques tous les
partis politiques à Bruxelles ont voté
pour les textes qui excluaient le
nucléaire je vous appelle parce qu'ici
le verbe est ha mais à faire des actions
positifes pour défendre le nucléaire
notre souveraineté et les Français et la
France d'abord entendu merci d'être venu
nous dire cela depuis Bruxelles je redne
parole à mes
collègues
alors euh bon sur sur la question de de
l'arenne en fait le retour à un tarif
réglementé fait que ça ça résout en fait
le le problème les constats qui ont été
fait sur
l'arène notre engagement c'est de
revenir à un tarif réglementé pour tous
et par une production publique
ou je pourrais dire autrement la
propriété publique des moyens de
production
euh
ensuite sur euh sur la la le la
photographie à l'instanté euh des
capacités de production et de projection
euh des prix euh en fait si c'est c'est
c'est possible ça a été renseigné hein
par de nombreuses recherches euh
auxquels je renvoie mais et de
nombreuses études euh et par ailleurs
peut-être euh j'en profite alors c'est
un peu ça combine un peu les les les
deux aspects mais
les scénarios RTE donc RTE envisage
plusieurs scénarios
de comment dire de bifurcation vers du
100 % renouvelable
ou dans la plupart en fait on se passe
du nucléaire donc c'est possible c'est
faisable et ça permet d'avoir en tête
absolument tous les aspects également
notamment ceux de la visibilité sur les
prix euh et j'ai oublié la dernière
question en fait moi c'était sur le
nucléaire donc je viens de
répondre non non je viens de répondre
oui alors en ce qui concerne la la
question de l'arine alors il y a nouveau
enfin il y a des négociations pour
réévaluer réévaluer
l'arine ce qui correspondrait à à
l'équivalent de contrat à long terme
donc cette arène serait réévaluée entre
60 et 70 € le mgaw donc ce qui
permettrait effectivement d'avoir un
réajustement au niveau de l'arine et
comme je dis ça ça serait un peu
l'équivalent d'un d'un contrat à à long
terme en ce qui concerne l'implantation
des éoliennes et je pense dans je
suppose dans vos dans vos territoires
nous avons voté une loi sur
l'accélération des énergies
renouvelables qui permet aussi de de
définir des zones d'accélération avec
des concertations avec la population
donc ce qui permettra aussi de aux élus
locaux et ça nous avionions bien insisté
dans cette loi d'accélération des
énergies renouvelables que les élus
locaux soient impliqués dans c'est dans
le choix des implantations des énergies
renouvelables dans la aussi dans la dans
la participation citoyenne donc dans la
concertation et en même temps dans le
partage de la valeur donc je vous je
vous amène à vous à vous référer à cette
loi en ce qui concerne l'implantation
des éoliennes sur notre territoire euh
bon après il faut aussi
peut-être déplorer ce le cette ce petit
incident concernant certains échanges au
cours de ce de ce rapport
cl c'est bon je peux je peux parler nos
échanges ont été cordiaux euh pendant le
le travail c'est un peu dommage que ça
soit un petit peu perturbé pendant le
rendu de de ce rapport
euh effectivement monsieur petit je
pense que au niveau de l'autonomie enfin
de notre de notre capacité
d'interconnexion entre les réseaux on ne
peut pas avoir le beurre et demander
l'argent du beurre en même temps
c'est-à-dire qu'on ne peut pas se dire
veut se se connecter être rester
connecté au réseau et ensuite vouloir
faire ce qu'on veut avec les prix du
marché donc à un moment donné il faut
trancher il faut choisir et c'est ce que
l'État français a fait donc on reste
connecté au réseau mais aussi en même
temps on reste connecté au marché euh en
ce qui concerne les les les prix le vrai
prix de de que le les Français doivent
doivent payer les les Français paieront
le vrai prix notamment avec avec ces ces
contrats pour la différence puisque
comme c'est expliqué dans le rapport et
que c'est un peu technique à expliquer
comme ça mais de toute manière il y aura
un prix plafond et si on va au-delà il y
a redistribution à l'état français et si
on va en de ça il y a une une
redistribution au niveau non si on va
au-delà il y a une redistribution au
consommateurs et si on va en de ça c'est
l'État qui prend en charge cette
différence donc ce qui permet de dire
que le on peut pas trouver quand même un
moyen plus protecteur pour les
consommateurs français que ce type de
contrat en ce qui concerne les PIP c'est
des contrats de gré à gré pour entre une
entreprise et un
producteur ce qu'ont besoin les
entreprises c'est de la prévisibilité
sur du long terme donc avec des contrats
qui peuvent qui seront contractés pour 4
5 ans les entreprises sauront que
pendant le auront connaîtront le prix de
leur de leur énergie de leur électricité
pour 4 à 5 ans et auront la possibilité
dans ce cas de pouvoir euh dans leur
budget prévisionnel prévoir tous leurs
investissement et ne seront pas soumises
à ces fluctuations que nous avons connu
notamment à l'automne dernier au niveau
du nucléaire nous allons et ça les
rapports RTE le disent très bien nous
avons nous allons avoir une augmentation
des besoins en électrification donc si
nous n'avons pas si nous ne trouvons pas
les moyens de produire notre électricité
nous avons dans ce mix énergétique
effectivement une grande part des
énergies renouvelables mais on sait tous
et ça je pense que c'est un peu démago
de de de ne pas le dire on le sait tous
les énergies renouvelables ne pourront
pas assumer tous les besoins en
électrification que nous aurons donc
comme nous nous comme ces énergies
renouvelables et bien sûr que nous nous
souhaitons tous avoir de l'énergie verte
et nous souhaitons tous avoir en en nos
mains des une énergie propre et
décarboné mais nous savons qu'elle ne
elle ça ne suffira pas donc nous avons
un moyen
décarboné qui a un coût de production
raisonnable et en même temps quand on
parle de déchets nucléaire et quand on
dit qu'on ne sait pas quoi en faire je
pense que les déchets nucléaires sont
quand même
les déchets on va dire les mieux traités
pour pour en ce qui concerne les voilà
la le le le traitement des déchets en
France euh donc oui il y a des déchets
ben personne ne le nit mais on a aussi
des nouvelles technologies qui vont
permettre de valoriser les les les
déchets on ne sait pas les traiter mais
je pense que quand on on voit que le
Japon revient sur la décision de fermer
la centrale nucléaire et justement est
en cours de de réflexion pour réouvrir
ou relancer le nucléaire sur son
territoire je il y a quand même des
questions à se poser quand on dit qu'on
ne veut pas de nucléaire dans notre mix
énergétique en ce qui concerne le biogaz
effectivement il y a ce biogaz servira
de
transition servira dans la transition
énergétique de notre pays et pour
l'instant le mot hydrogène n'a pas été
prononcé au cours de ce rendu de rapport
mais je pense que l'hydrogène à toute a
toute sa place dans cette transition
énergétique et enfin je voudrais en
finir sur le fait que nous n'avons pas
voté certaines lois mais je pense que au
Parlement européen
euh des membres les les membres les les
eurodéputés de de votre groupe n'ont pas
voté la directive sur les énergies
renouvelables n'ont pas voté la la
directive sur l'organisation du marché
de l'électricité de l'Union ù se sont
abstenus n'ont pas voté la directive sur
les carburants durables pour l'aviation
n'ont pas voter sur l' la directive sur
l'utilisation des carburants
renouvelables et et bac cararbone dans
le transport maritime n'ont pas voté ou
se sont abstenus sur le déploiement
d'une infrastr des infrastructures pour
carburants alternatifs ils n'ont pas
voté pour la directive sur l'efficacité
énergétique ils n'ont pas voté pour la
refonte de la directive performance
énergétique des bâtiments ils n'ont pas
voté pour la réduction des émissions de
méthane dans le secteur de l'énergie ils
n'ont pas voté
sur les chapitres sur certains chapitres
du du plan RIP power euu des plans pour
la reprise et la résilience et je et je
ne vous pas et je vous passe le volet
sur les industries donc nous n'avons pas
de leçons à
recevoir merci beaucoup mesdames les
rapporteurs pour vos interventions j'ai
une dernière demande de prise de parole
de Madame Chikirou que je demanderis
d'être bref parce qu'il y a un autre
rapport et qui a la séance en même temps
merci
beaucoup second
ouais allezy euh monsieur le Président
je suis vraiment navrée mais moi je dois
absolument aller en séance et je devais
intervenir sur le rapport donc je je
trouve que c'est compliqué là d'être
présent j'ai pas le don d'hubiquuité
mais la ce qui se vote en ce moment en
séance est décisif et très important
l'article 5 va passer moi je je pense
qu'en terme d'organisation peut-être
qu'il faut suspendre au moins le temps
du vote sur l'article 5 et qu'on puisse
aller revenir quoi parce que j'ai aussi
une intervention à faire sur le rapport
de de ma collègue socialiste qui elle
aussi est chef de fil sur le le sen
actuellement donc nous on est très
embêté parce que là on est sur deux
sujets cruciaux l'austérité budgétaire
en Europe et le le vote sur le numérique
en pleine séance là sur l'article 5 on
peut pas rater ça monsieur le Président
je
dem comprend je comprends votre demande
madame Chikirou mais malheureusement
vous comprenez bien que la commission
des affaires européennes est une
commission non permanente qu'elle se
réunit quand elle peut se réunir que je
pourrais tout à fait suspendre 2h pour
la reprogrammer 2h plus tard avec avec
un ou deux députés et par ailleurs les
rapporteurs sont présents ici mais ils
ont d'autres engagements par ailleurs
donc cette audition a été prévue il y a
longtemps je pouvais pas savoir à
l'avance que ça all être concomitant du
vote sur l'article 5 donc ce que je suis
vraiment désolé mais je pourrais pas
accéder à votre demande parce que le
rapporteur en l'occurrence les
rapporteurs ont d'autres engagements par
la
suite on pourra on pourra inscrire au
compte-rendu autre
intervention très bien merci ah c'est
dommage mais je suis sûr vous aurez
d'autres d'autres prises de parole à
faire merci beaucoup je vous propose que
l'on passe à l'autre à l'autre rapport
oui madame GAM parce que vous voulez
répondre 30 secondes allez-y oui 30
secondes je vous rappelle que dans le
cadre inflationniste dans lequel nos
compatriotes sont en train de survivre
nous votons contre et nous absenons
systématiquement tout tout ce qui remet
en question notre filière nucléaire et
qui remet en question leur pouvoir
d'achat dans un contexte où je vous
rappelle les français ne peuvent plus
chauffer et pour certains n'ont plus
qu'un repas par jour merci beaucoup nous
en venons je vous remercie pour ses
prises de parole est-ce que la
Commission est d'accord pour autoriser
le dépôt du rapport d'information
oui il en est ainsi décidé merci et je
propose que l'on passe au rapport
suivant et j'invite Madame caramanli et
Monsieur hroy à nous rejoindre pour les
la révision des règles budgéaires du
PACT de stabilité et j'en profite aussi
pour
remercier Monsieur Marcelo qui était le
administrateur sur le rapport précédent
et Madame jade Chana qui l'a accompagné
je crois sur ce travail pendant un temps
merci beaucoup